It takes its name from the Arabic word for emptiness al Zahara
But the Sahara is really a collection of deserts and the most remote is the Tenere
I sit had to cross the ténéré in the way caravans have done for a thousand years
it'll mean a journey of 1,200 miles over rock and sand by vehicle camel and on foot and
It's a dangerous journey
For in the sweltering dessicated furnace death strikes the week the ill-prepared or the unlucky
They call it the land of fear
My name is David Adams and as a photojournalist, I've made a point of going to some of the world's most remote places
My journey starts in the African Republic of nazir a former French colony where the Tenere meets the iya mountains
Which is why I'm in the ancient city of Agra des
AGGA des is a mud city and there seems no end to the patterns that clay and straw can achieve
It's also a holy city of Islam
This mosque claiming to have one of the highest mud minarets in all of Africa
It's a city that got rich on trade less than a hundred years ago
Slaves gold and ivory were sold here in the Agadez markets
Just love the chaos of these markets in Africa, you can get absolutely anything and everything's being bargained and it's all over the place
sugar cane onions brain from Niger and then there's this stuff salt has actually been the mainstay of
This whole area of Africa for probably more than a thousand years and it's the great salt caravans that bring it here
This is Caravan central first port of call after crossing the wilderness
From north south east and west they converge on Agadez
Because it straddles one of the great desert crossroads of africa
Everything about these markets is geared to caravans
clothing footwear head wear even a haircut
Meat drinks and fruit for a lengthy desert crossing and of course food for the camels, too
Doesn't look very happy do they I
Think you probably really upset because he can't eat it
It's sort of the reverse of having a carrot hanging in front of you if you've got lunch on your back and you can't do
Anything about it?
This is truly stepping back in time here, we are at the dawn of a new millennium and there are still people wearing swords
They're called the Tuareg
Not people that you'd want to mess with
Only 18 months earlier they were in full armed rebellion against the nisha government
So if you want to travel to the desert and survive you need their help
Which is why I've got to go a hundred and twenty miles to the north
That's 200 kilometers to chammiya a place famous for its camel races
Here, I'll find the people. I need to get me across the Tanner a
So these are the people I'd come to meet the
Legendary warriors of the desert and they wouldn't look out of place in a Star Wars movie either
The Tuareg once ran an empire that controlled the central Sahara no caravan could pass without their say-so
There are many theories about their origins some say they're one of the Lost Tribes of Israel
Others that they were originally Christian hence the prevalence of the cross as a Tuareg motive
But today they're Muslim and in stark contrast of the Islamic norm
It's the men who cover their faces while the women live there is unveiled
The Tuareg are fiercely competitive many of them riding up to four days just to take part in this race
And today that's all it is Oh grace not long ago that have lined up like this for a warrior's charge
They're off and there's lots of just links the league which sometimes leads to accidents
In what an awesome sight
these are the sentence of desert pirates who as recently as the
1990s were still raiding caravans with Lars and sword
Somehow I don't think nature ever designed a camel to gallop
It's more of an awkward wallop half Kanter half trot not very comfortable for the rider
And it isn't a race for the faint-hearted
The course is just over two miles of three and a half kilometres
Plodding across the tannery with a caravan won't be quite like this
It takes ten minutes to cross the line
And when they do it'll be to the chairs of their women and the jeers of their rivals
It's going to be interesting crossing the desert of men like these
There'll be many races today and in between the dancing a
Chance for the Warriors a little stain and for me a chance to take some photographs
Perfect moments like this when there's an amazing picture and your camera breaks
This is my panoramic and there's no working
Will never happen again
Bond they dance until the prize-giving and this is the prize a
Legendary sword of the Tuareg the takabe, and it's certainly not a toy
Every Tuareg month
But today they're more for show he says a symbol of manliness
But for a weapon that's just a symbol. It's extraordinarily sharp the perfect prize for a warrior
So these racers are about more than just rewarding winners they're about creating legends
It's as if we're back in the Middle Ages in the time of the Moors prasada Knights and tales of chivalry and honor
And
Preparing to cross the desert to help me a team of Tuareg will show me the way to the tannery and beyond
Camping equipment tools spare wheels and spare parts of diesel fuel medical suppliers
rations for three weeks and of course
plenty of water
We decided not to take tents
It hasn't rained in the Tenere for 15 years and it isn't likely to for another 15, but I did bring these
Anywhere without the old skis
We're heading north into bandit country, our route takes us through the hard measures higher mountains
This was a crier egg stronghold during the rebellion
It's desert, all right, but just in case you're wondering where the sand dunes and mirages are
Well relatively little of the Sahara is sand you and a hell of a lot of it is mountainous
Some of these Arab peeps are over 7,000 feet high I wanted to explore them
I wanted to go deep into them when no European had ever gone and
To do that I had to start in the isolated town of if you are
Here everything is improvised buckets become drums wires become toys and an old plastic container will do as a soccer ball
If I'd have been walking down these streets 18 months earlier there's a fair chance but have been kidnapped and held for ransom
This was a Tuareg headquarters during the rebellion today all is quiet and I'm just a figure of curiosity
Word was getting out that there was a stranger in town
Maybe I'd like to ride a camel. If so, wouldn't I like to buy a saddle?
Or maybe one of those murderers Tuareg so
This is a really old one. Looks like these are the old alchemy moon symbols
That would show you only find on the really old swords
An answer in selling anything
But why would I want to buy it when I can get one made to order
These must be some of the world's last sword smiths to make swords for combat a
Blade of the finest cutting steel which 500 years ago would have come from European cities like Toledo or Padua
Today's taco bar is more likely to have been forged out of Toyota bumpers
I'm looking for a guide
Yeah, because I want to go from from million across the mountains into the tin rain I can do yeah
Yeah, do you have camels have coming because I would like to go either today or tomorrow?
Okay
And that's how I came to meet Koya abdul rahman
Irr a man who become my guide and mentor a man has helped me to understand
about tuara culture
That in the desert lawyers family live a nomadic life moving from Camp to camp with their animals in search of feed
So the family has been here for three weeks
They need to be near water
Not too near an old custom forbids Tuareg to camp nearer than five miles from water
List their children go up taking it for granted
It's rare that one gets the chance to meet the Tuareg at firsthand. Oh and what a greeting
It means how are you? How are your parents your family your children your grandparents and so on
David
The third one is my my wife
His name was Carla, I was quite a bizarre heat
Absorbed oh, yeah absorbs out. And what does it mean?
What is although he I?
Give him this name depend his color. Yeah, so also means white the white up. So it's white but not very white is
Not very very white is near white. Ha ha ha
So it's on absol that I'll ride into the ténéré
perched on a Tuareg saddle with what looked like sharp trident shaped handlebars the
Spikes for these ones
Protection for inaudible from the sword also when they were fighting this is so that you didn't get captured by. Oh I
Thought it was for me to hang on to
Saddle cloths provisions and a traditional water bottle made of goat skins, but there's something missing and
Where are the stirrups, there are no stirrups master. Ok
Camels and committees and this one looks particularly well designed
Also go very good temperament I think now this is the easy way of mounting a camel
If you want to do it the Tuareg
Just grab its chin climb up on its neck and spring into the settle before it bites you easy
So off we ride into the mountains towards one of the highest peaks in the ayah, add Ratan gak
As we go Oya sings me songs about his Tuareg heroes and their exploits in battle
And I demand an RBI
Oh
Honest
I mean
Is love
Shekhar
We're heading up a dry riverbed through the town gack corridor the start of a major caravan route to the tannery
So it's a bit of a surprise to get our feet wet quite so soon
It was the last water we'd see for over a week
By now, I'm getting to know her not long ago. He was a wealthy man who owned over a hundred camels
But he got caught up in the Tuareg rebellion against the nisha government had absolutely ruined him leaving him with just these two
Cameras in the rebellion many of his friends were killed
Not a lot
As I was to discover Islam is central to Hoyas life when our spray it means I was
Take contact with good I pray for him. I must do this for ham fine. I would ask him
What I'm what I want
That night hire brood a part of strong Tuareg minted tea which has to be poured back into the pot three times
Why do you poured three times three times is something?
We see with our ancestors if it was embodied one T or two was not happy. It's not good. It's not a good thing
It's a tradition for our ancestors
Next morning, we've got company a family of baboons appears from nowhere in the middle of this iron mountain wilderness
It's a big one. Yeah, I see it in before the chief is sitting on this big stone here suppose
This is the big black ones. There are at once - yeah
they didn't stay together because
There they fight again, right?
And that's not a yawn it's a threat his way of letting you know that you've come quite close enough
But what's so amazing is that they're here at all in an arid place like this as
It happens their relics from a different age
Wow looks like a whole family. It's a family thing
Maybe around
Their animals long gone from this desolate wilderness yet. Their images have been faithfully recorded in stone
It just goes to show the power of climate change
When Tutankhamun sat on the Egyptian throne and King Solomon ruled Israel
This would have been lush savanna land with plenty of game for hunter-gatherers
Whoever carved these seven to ten thousand years ago
Sat here in a very different landscape than I do because what he saw out on the plains was giraffe
Ibex and all the other animals here on these rocks and all I can see is Jones
There before me is what I've come all this way to see the great tenor a desert
Washing like a gigantic ocean of sand across the rocky coastline of the air mountains
So reunited with my vehicles we head off into the desert with Hoya coming along as my guide
Towards midday in the 10r a
burning Sun heats the sand her over 110 degrees not good for driving even for our Tuareg friends and
They're some of the world's best desert 4-wheel drivers
Oh, it's what I think it's not so easy we might be having lunch
Problem is that the Sun is so hot at the moment that all the sand is really really light
And so the kind of attraction we may even have to wait till late in the afternoon
So we let air out of our tires
deflated tires cover more surface area and gain more traction and
Once into the real desert we can get up quite a speed
Once into the Tenere all the desert is a road where each car makes its own track
But Wyrick always drive information always inside of one another
Yet you can get lost in a mirage long before you ever reach the horizon
Here the sand is firm and the drive is easy
But where the dunes are soft and steep that's where their driving skills really kick in
The trick seems to be to run up to the crest
Break at the very last moment and then let the car gently slide down and there you go
But sometimes even the Tuareg get it wrong
It was our first accident and we're 400 miles from the nearest service station
Pull it down into the compartment when they hit the ground it also ripped out the tire from underneath
And when they collected the ground in front, it's actually bend up this really large bumper bar
It's serviceable, but I think it's going to cost us quite a bit
It was a rather violent introduction to some of the most serene sand dunes on earth
This is actually a giant meteorite crater
Eric ow, and right now the light is absolutely perfect
I have to say
I've been waiting all my life to come and sit here and watch a sunset like this across these dunes
These are some of the biggest in the world
And for the next couple of hours in early tomorrow morning the colors and these shapes will just change and change and change
and for this
And taking the photos here is absolutely heaven 3
The shapes are incredibly sensual curves and ripples made crisp in the red evening light
And as the last rays of Desert Sun slip over the horizon and the sand dunes cease to glow a
Revel in this photographers dream
Okay the next morning
I wanted to have a crack at the world's highest sand dune and do it on skis my friends thought I was absolutely crazy
This sand hill is a little over
300 meters high that's almost a thousand feet and the Tuareg told me it has never been skied before
The trouble is the nearest ski lift is over 2,000 miles away and it was hot very hot
Every step I take here seems to be
Two steps back and this Ridge seems further and further away. Hey, every time I take the next step
Getting up here on the ridge this view is absolutely incredible
These dark riches behind me that just burn in this Sun and then turns away into the distance across this amazing crater
I can see everything
Fantastic, huh ready? That's harder than snipers. Yeah
Just having gone up there and skied down on your legs kind of get really tired because you can't move properly. I
Don't know if anybody's done that before but um, I had a hat off to him if they had. Oh
I love some water. Please somebody
Say I've been really stupid or taking it up
One week into our desert journey and we're now well into the tannery and I have a caravan to catch
We're heading into the heart of Nazir's sand ocean and the analogy isn't a bad one
Here in the middle of North Africa, it feels as if you're really crossing the sea
The Tenere takes its name from the Tuareg word for nothingness
So we're crossing a nothingness the size of France in the middle of an emptiness the size of the United States
Donavan sometimes they're comers who died during the caravan there comers who died. This is one of them
Yeah
Death Comes quickly here in the ten rang go without water for eight hours and you start to die
And your body doesn't rot. It's so dry out here even bacteria
struggle to survive
No wonder they call it the land of fear
Yet for centuries Tuareg caravans have been crossing it and we're on the trail of one right now
Caravan truck see. Oh, yeah Caravan proxy. We don't know exactly would I want to I will go and see whether
No need for Global Positioning satellites out here they use organic navigation camel droppings
Look Seth looks dry
Looks dry how many days three days I don't maybe three days
So not so far by the car I don't under the metal sweetheart, okay
Then in the middle of nowhere we see bales of hay
It's a camel take out our supply duck. Our Caravan can't be far ahead now
On and on for the nothingness we go until a strange shimmering line starts to resolve on the horizon
It's the caravan
Once more it seems as if time has Stood Still things have hardly changed since the Middle Ages
With satellites high above here. They are navigating their way with pinpoint precision
Through the turnaround and not a compass in size
This is the same Caravan that's been dropping off. Hey all along the route so when they return they can feed their camels
Using the Sun the wind and the Stars to guide them they'll find it again easily
But they have a problem a boy with a badly infected hand luckily as part of our supplies, we have a medical
Kits now look we can do with him and he probably needs pretty serious attention to it
But hopefully we can stop the infection and clean it up
But it's much better treatment than he'd normally get out here in a place where the nearest medical help is hundreds of miles away
And it's nothing good he'll he will lose his arm if his wound turns gangrenous could be a stark choice
amputation
All of this brings the dangers of desert travel into sharp focus
While the ténéré is awesomely beautiful, there's no margin for error no support something goes wrong
By now endearing one of the most isolated outposts in the country of Lisieux the town of Billman
And how's this for water ski practice well at least there aren't any sharks out here
Deal
We've done about two hundred and twenty miles across this sand ocean and my Tuareg friends have navigated us perfectly
No, thanks to this though
and
Again on a maritime note, what would you expect to see on the other side of an ocean but a lighthouse?
It's just that the real ocean is a thousand miles away
It was part of a whole string of them built around the ténéré in the 1930s
It's abandoned now, but it had a distinctly colonial purpose
Because this wasn't actually built for the Tuareg because they don't need
Navigation in the desert they've got their own it was built for the French army, so they wouldn't get lost
This is the oasis town of Bill Maher and here there's plenty of fresh water
It bubbles out of the ground crystal-clear turning the desert into a tropical garden
But it's surprising to discover that most of this fresh water is turned into salt water
deliberately
Because there's so much salt in the ground water is poured into these pools to leach it out the burning Sun does the rest
In temperatures of way over 110 degrees or 50 degrees Celsius the water quickly evaporates leaving the salt behind
It's here that an old Bible story comes to life they make pillars of salt
You're looking at an industry that hasn't changed for thousands of years
There's a shortage of salt in the Sahara
so Bill Mersault still finds its way to just about every corner of North Africa, which is why Bill Maher attracts the caravans
Not far from the salt pans
It's a mass of bellowing fighting cud-chewing camels all waiting to start a two-week journey back across the tannery
There's a caravan leaving soon
Laura and I will be joining it but first he needs to buy some salt for his animals back home
Now I discover something else about my companion he's fussy about his salt
So much that he literally puts it to the litmus test
if it's a good fault, it will come orange if it is not good you to explain like
That was the easy no now comes the haggling and we're only talking about a deal worth $6
It harks back to the days when salt was a common in and out here it still is
Indeed the word salary comes from solarium Latin for salt
The money that was paid to the Roman legions to buy their salt rations
In all my travels I don't think I've ever seen so many camels
every year they reckon some
25,000 pass through Billman
Each of these salt pillars weighs about 65 pounds or 30 kilos
So with a six pillar load on a good strong camel, that's nearly a quarter of a ton
So it's not surprising there's a great deal of complaining at loading time
But once loaded they settle down our Caravan finally gets underway
How many times have you because the generator
Since you were this big
we've just embarked on a
370 mile trip across the channel that's 600 kilometers a journey of more than two weeks
When walking with caravans lesson number one, never underestimate its speed
While camels amble at what seems to be a dignified pace their legs are long and you need to walk briskly just to keep her
So, how many camels are we go? Yeah, and here's lesson number two
That's maybe 300
We didn't
Know but you know the back it is a number of nobody will
Force period yeah, it's not good
I touched on a Tuareg nerve if you count your camels one may die. So it's better to remain ignorant
And during a caravan you soon realize how effective Tuareg robes are they preserve moisture
So how much water would these men drink every day riding on the caravan?
Just three cups of water each day. Well, I was drinking the nearly gallon or more than five litres
There's a Tuareg saying it's too hard to talk. So they're like a camel a
hundred miles down
275 more to go that's about 500 kilometres
But many of these caravans go a lot further
Right across Africa without any regard for international borders and the borders on a problem. You just cannot release no problem in
Because Touareg like
Freedom you think that there is no board from him in his mind. There's no board
Everywhere is for him
At last I was beginning to get a handle on these proud of desert travelers gentle and hospitable, but
Fiercely independent and it's something they're prepared to fight for
So what does it mean to be a Tuareg? Is it freedom simply or is there more there are more?
freedom fest
anything
Anything to terrorize the deep desert, yeah the desert tannery and there is so many I
Don't know kill kill kill
Which means really and the Tuareg obligation to respect
The following morning as the blue pre-dawn Twilight spreads across the Tenere hundreds of camels are on the moon
Silently crossing this remarkable desert in both directions
And
If you ever thought that the middle of the Sahara was the middle of nowhere we'll think again
This nowhere is a superhighway
The Tenere is alive with caravans
It would be a mistake to think of caravans in terms of crude Western commerce
To a Tuareg the caravan is a symbol of the journey of life
No one here is a complete man until he's crossed the desert with a caravan at least once
So on I go day after day night after night
falling further under the spell of this Tuareg sense of freedom and independence and
with Hoyas help
I have completed this rite of passage and
Crossed one of the world's remotest deserts on another of my journeys to the ends of the earth